friends friends
let us talk
about
poetry
let us talk
about
poetry what did robin williams saying
dead poets society we don't read and
write poetry because it's cute
we read and write poetry because we are
members of the human race and the human
race is filled with passion
science business engineering these are
noble pursuits necessary to sustain life
but poetry
freedom love romance
these are the things we stay alive for
do you realize not
that without poetry life would be a
mistake like nietzsche wrote without
music life would be a mistake without
art life would be a mistake without
beauty life would be a mistake we don't
read
poetry
we let it drip from our lips
like honey
spirits soar women swoon
and gods are created
not a bad bait not a bad way to spend an
evening eh
it is these words of professor keating
or robin williams and dead poets society
that so have spoken to my soul that so
have
taught me a profound
lesson about the things that matter in
life about the role of passion of
curiosity these noble these noble
worthwhile endeavors the things that
matter
beauty truth freedom
and above all
love
friends
we don't read and write poetry because
it's cute we read and write poetry
because it's us
the art that moves you reveals you we
read and write poetry because we are
members of the human race and the human
race is filled with passion
we are filled with passion
we are dripping with passion we are
naked
with passion we are pulsating we are
throbbing with passion we don't read and
write poetry because it's cute we read
and write poetry because we are members
of the human race and the human race is
filled with passion
i went to god just to see
and i was looking at me
we free
the brave reckless gods that live inside
us
we set ourselves on fire
he who must save his life
must first lose it
these poetic words of
rapture
and surrender
and poetry friends
are indicative i think
of the need
to make of our lives
a lived mythology
to carve our name on a tree to act like
it matters
to endow
our lives
with poetry
stop trying to make art
and become art
and become